well to code in DNA so it is a storage
talk and I would like to thank some
great people I worked with two synthetic
biologists one by informatician a bunch
of coding theorists and let me try to
get you excited about DNA based storage
and synthetic biology in general because
it's a source of great problems for
coding theorists very recently there has
been a lot of interest in the bio
community to start using DNA as the
media for either communicating
information storing information and all
the attempts basically clicked came in
the last two three years and they
received a lot of media attention so one
of the results that I want to bring up
came was published in Nature 2013 by a
group that involves two very prominent
biologists Goldman and Bernie and they
tried to play to the media they encoded
DNA in DNA all of Shakespeare's work
they're stationed at Cambridge and you
see Goldman here looking at a tiny drop
of water which has Shakespeare it has
the encoding of I have a dream speech a
bunch of images and obviously the media
took this idea very far and they
predicted that DNA is the new silicon of
the future that one should start
thinking about using macromolecules
instead of other systems for storing and
communicating and what is interesting is
Goldman and Bernie the people that
design the first DNA based storage
system are knowledge david mackay at the
very end of their paper for pointing out
to them what Halfmann codes are what
differential coding is and what parity
checks are so it's like it's very nice
to see that the David McKay was involved
in it and the reason why we are
interested and I think it's really an
exciting problem which is not just there
for media attention but in general is
that DNA has some unique properties that
you will not find for other media and my
one of Michael Jordan former students
gave a brilliant talk at Urbana recently
where he talked about how we managed to
extract Neanderthal genome from roughly
40,000 years ago
Neanderthals went extinct then and
basically he showed us how using that
deal
which was very well preserved he managed
to find admixture events god forbid
events where Neanderthals and humans
made it in the past so if you're
interested please check out some of
these papers and why is it a technology
that we should trust or believe in
because of the fact that no system or no
technology has been as disruptive as
genomics lately and biotechnology prices
are going down prices of both DNA strand
synthesis and sequencing are gradually
going down and in the recent past they
have been going down really
exponentially so synthesizing DNA you
can view it abstractly as a right
process sequencing the DNA as a read
process and there is something like a
extremely harsh trend of decrease in the
sequencing cost of a genome and that has
been well documented and documented and
people are using these lights to try to
tell you that nowadays we can sequence
the whole human genome for less than a
thousand dollars if you go to 23andme
you can sequence your own genome and get
your mutations and everything you
probably don't want to know for 99
dollars so if you think of the cost of
DNA synthesis it's a bit high so to
synthesize trends and this tells you
basically the what we are going to use
as block lengths lengths of DNA strands
the cost in u.s. dollars is something
that digital technology is definitely
doing much better but as an example for
the system that we built when we started
maybe two years ago we used to pay
roughly two thousand dollars for a
sequence of length thousand which is
very expensive but once we're in the
last experiments roughly six months ago
we paid only two hundred dollars for the
same sequences so the prices are really
going down abruptly and besides the
prices and the costs of the system one
consider constrained that we have to
worry about is that it's also
computationally expensive to deal with
these systems and I'd explain that in
more detail later on but the
computational expense comes from the
problem of DNA assembly that some of you
may have heard about and the problem is
basically one of stitching substrings of
a sequence to
in a smart and an efficient way so what
did we do
since this conference is about practice
to theory I'll start with practice we
developed the first rewritable and
random-access DNA storage system so
Goldman and Burnie and church and
kasoori from Harvard developed archival
storage system and if you read the paper
you will realize that if you want to
read one line from Shakespeare
what what's in a name for example you
would have to stitch every single read
together basically flip through all his
books in order to find that one line so
random access was not enabled but the
other thing that was not enabled was
rewriting so we took it up upon us to
design a system a tiny system don't look
at the numbers where we encoded
Wikipedia information and this was not
for propaganda purposes my student was
obsessed with encoding UIUC information
in DNA I wouldn't have been that loyal I
know it this is recorded but don't quote
me later on so here's an example of what
we coded a piece of that information
being coded and another thing my student
was curious about is how to basically
change the budget that Urbana has
exponentially decreasing when the stored
information in DNA so here here are some
of the results all biology talks have to
have some nice pictures two more
pictures and then we'll start formulas
this here is something that tells you
that you should interpret as yes we can
do random access because we have three
tracks here and three stripes light
stripes they tell you that we managed to
out of a pool of a tunnel of DNA
sequences select three sequences the
light the light stripes tell you that we
got the right lines so we can access we
can access the right parts the right
length of the sequences and then we can
read and rewrite them by using
amplification methods and methods that
are very known in DNA editing systems
known as G block and overextension PCR
and we can we sequence the data to make
sure that we didn't make any mistakes
during the rewrite and access procedure
and
is what is called Sanger sequencing it's
a bit costly it's a method that works
for shorter strings when you can do to
pass sequencing we had no errors you see
everything in yellow which means you can
do these processes without errors
but what is disturbing is that all of
this was this pleasure was $4,500 so I'm
not saying you're here in terms of cost
but hopefully in the near future things
are going to look very different so this
was the practice part a few pretty
pictures or not so pretty pictures and
let's now go to the mathematical model
so as you can only assume there was a
lot of twisting and turning to make the
system work it's not as pretty as I'm
going to show you in the next few slides
but we can come up with the slight let's
say it's light abstraction that will
appeal to the audience of information
theorists of what we call the DNA
storage channel so let's look at the
system from this perspective so I have a
DNA sequence a strand and I I want to
use that strength to store information
so the first thing I would have to do as
a synthetic biologist I would have to
synthesize the string so the synthesis
channel is the channel where which
allows you to create the sequence and it
obviously introduces errors because it's
a sequence of complicated biochemical
processes so let's say you wanted to see
a synthesize X you actually synthesized
another string and for simplicity let's
assume that the synthesis channel as you
will see in a second introduces
substitution errors so for example you
and I'm showing you everything in binary
the results hold for curity channels as
well but it's simpler to show it in
binary
so the synthesis channel just view it as
a channel which introduces substitution
errors and this is our right process or
our right channel and depending on the
technology you use for synthesis the
error rates can be as high as 1% a lot
of the systems have lower error rates so
the next thing you want to do is once
you read the information you obviously
want to once you write the information
you want to read it and this is where
you get to the so-called sequencing
channel and this is something that
probably even would never think about in
our area if it weren't for the bio
problem what is the sequencing channel
it's the read channel and we don't read
DNA as a whole sequence we can only read
DNA based on the fragments or l grams of
the sequence so for example I had a
synthesis error here you notice that I
have a 1 here
and this information now has to be
pushed through a sequencing channel this
drink which will do the following it
will take all sub strings let's say of
length L of this sequence 1 0 1 0 1 1 1
1 1 1 1 0 and so forth
and potentially drop some fragments
because there's the problem of coverage
that modern sequencing devices have to
deal with so I don't get to observe all
the fragments I just get to observe some
fragments or some substrings of this
string and now I have to read those sub
strings I have to perform actual
sequencing and what will happen is that
some of these sub strings themselves
will get errors so for example I lost
the substring and here I have a
substring where a 1 got converted into a
0 and this is the this is the process of
introducing errors during in let's say
Illumina machines which have error rates
about 1% the read length sorry or the L
grams are usually hundred so you can
think of L as hundred and what you get
is really an interesting input/output
channel where you put a sequence in and
at the output you get a subset of sub
strings which may have errors and the
errors we have are pretty interesting
because first of all when I synthesize
the sequence and I make an error that
error may propagate up to within ll
grams because each of these symbols it
was wrongly synthesized may end up in a
certain number of sub strings and then
each of these sub strings may have an
individual error in it and what I
observe is a bunch of sub strings which
which that have potential proper
potentially propagated error from the
synthesis Channel and potential
sequencing errors and potentially
missing substrings and what makes sense
to look at this model is the so called
profile vector or type vector of a
substring because if I'm giving an input
sequence 1 0 0 0 like in this example
the output shell at the output of the
channel will be basically a count on how
many substrings of certain type did I
observe in the mixture so for example if
I look at this string here I see that I
observed 1 0 1 I'll write the 1 here I
observed 0 1 1 and I observed it twice
because of this error here so I'll write
it twice and I observed 0 times 1 1 1 I
observe 0 times 0 0 0 and this is what
we call the substring composition type
or profile vector of the output and
notice that the profile vector of the
output is different from the profile
vector of the original sequences you
started from because you had synthesis
errors and you had sequencing errors so
here is the situation again this was
your actual set of symbols or bits that
you wanted to store this is the actual
profile of the output while the profile
of the input was something else because
you made a bunch of mistakes so this guy
here is the profile vector of the input
this guy here is the profile at the
output so then the question of interest
is basically how do we code or how do we
design code words so that the at the
output when we observe these profile
vectors we can distinguish the code
words at the input so we have to have
some distance measure and you're going
to introduce this distance measure in a
pretty simple way we are going to
introduce the distance measure on the
profile vectors themselves so what is
what are some of the coding criteria we
are interested in we want to have some
error control coding property here we
want the profile vectors of our chosen
code words to be as far as possible from
each other so for example if I get this
profile at the output of the channel and
I know the two code words were possible
either this code word or this what I'll
do is I'll compute the profiles of these
code words or the types of these code
words and I compare it with the type at
the output and what distance measure
should I use an obvious choice and this
is explained in our paper in more detail
is to use the asymmetric distance
between the profiles so I am going to
compute the asymmetric distance by
looking at two strings and the maximum
of the pairwise differences sum it up
and then just take the maximum of the
this pairwise distance when I change the
order of U and V and V and U so this is
what is well known in the coding theory
community as the asymmetric distance and
obviously based on the description of
the system you can tell that our one of
the code design criteria is that we want
to have codes which have the property
that their profiles after a certain
number and types of errors will be as
distinct from each other as possible and
yes please we have basically what you do
is there are different methods one
solution we came up with we use the DNA
microarray that gives you light
intensity for four it's an array of
spots which can eat each one of these
spots can identify one substring oh
sorry now go ahead maybe I misunderstood
oh oh I'll talk about that in a second
okay thank you thank you
the broening graphs the broening graphs
the answer is the brown graphs that's
very frequently used sorry I thought
you're asking about the biology so
another set of problems which I won't
discuss it but I'll talk a little bit
when I describe the underlying graph
models for this problem is constrained
coding and that comes from the fact that
we know how let's say luminous
sequencers or how
read channels make mistakes for examples
we know that in order for the system to
make as few sequencing errors we need a
balance of CG bases which is roughly 50%
we should avoid some substrings in the
DNA like CGC or huge islands long
islands of GNC symbols and that gives
some very interesting constraint coding
problems that I probably won't have too
much time to talk about and in this
constrained coding problem what really
comes up is this bunch of fundamental
questions so back to Michael's question
the first question is how do we stitch
back together or how do we first
basically not stitch together back the
vectors or the code words from the
profiles but the first thing we want to
know is how many different profiles are
there and you can imagine it's not hard
to see that there exist many words that
may share the same profile so there are
actually equivalence classes when it
comes to profile vectors and we are
obviously don't go only going to choose
one representative from each profile
class and we want to know if you're
looking at profiles with respect to that
equivalence class how many different
profile vectors or equivalence classes
are there and then the second question
we are going to ask is if you look at
this asymmetric distance how many code
words or profiles are they going to be
there are at certain distance from each
other
certain asymmetric distance and the new
type of codes we call Algrim
reconstruction codes and we can do this
for any set of parameters doesn't have
to be binary the length of the code
words is an alphabet size Q we can
change the length of TL l grams or the
strings which is basically the read
length and we can change the set of
constraints we want to deal with on the
properties of the reads and on top of it
we have a minimum distance constraint so
now to Michael's question how do we
accomplish all this we nearly really
need to use techniques from the drawing
graph theory and that work has
originated from Pavel PES Group one of
the big by informaticians and it's been
you
DNA assembly problems for many years now
probably 20 years or longer and here is
the very straightforward application of
the brine graphs just think of the the
brine graph containing sap containing
the substring of length L minus 1 so you
get your L grams so take the prefix of
length L minus 1 and the suffix of
length L minus 1 so for example here if
I had L is equal to 3 I would take
binary vectors of length 2 and that the
broening graph is the graph where it's a
directed graph where you go from a
vertex labeled by a sequence in this
case 1 0 to another sequence in such a
way that the suffix of length L minus L
minus 1 in this case is the same as the
prefix of the sequence that you follow
through this edge so for example here I
have 1 0 and this 0 is the same 0 as
this one and I add an innovation of a
symbol 0 so I get 1 0 0 for the label of
the edge and this is what is standardly
known as the de bruyne graph and you can
extend it was work very recent work I
couldn't believe that people didn't
think about this earlier you can extend
this to restricted the growing graph
where the substrings are no longer
necessarily such that they cover all the
L Graham possible all the possibilities
for L grams of strings so for example I
can only restrict myself to have a
specialized the prone graph where the
labels of the vertices are strings of
certain weight for example here the only
nodes you see are nodes where the
sequences have length 2 or 2 or 1 as 2
or 3 sorry 2 or 3 what we're looking at
is really the labels of the edges not
not the vertices and this is what is
called a restricted de Bruyne graph
because I'm not going to work with all
the the complete state space I'm just
going to look at as
space where I take strings of a certain
form so that the edges have let's say
restricted weight or some other property
so this is what we call restricted the
prying drafts and here's an interesting
property if we look at closed words in
such a closed words meaning words that
begin and start with the same Algrim so
this guy here is a closed word because
you start with 0 1 1 and you end with 0
1 1 and we're dealing with L is equal to
3 here this guy here is not a closed
word because 1 0 and 0 1 are not the
same sequences if you deal with closed
words words then you can associate that
word and walks or flows in this graph
with the profile vectors and before I
say what the flow is or before I say how
this Association comes about
remember this was our input sequence or
let's say the sequence whose profile we
are looking at and you notice that this
sequence here has two sub strings 1 0 0
and another 1 0 0 so I will add a flow
from this vertex to this vertex of
weight 2 because I have 2 sub strings 1
0 0 so it means that if I'm going to do
sequence reconstruction and this is how
you really go back from profile to
string I would have to pass this edge
twice so the flows basically tell you
how many times do you have to traverse
the given edge when you do
reconstruction but they also tell you
the profile vectors in some sense and if
I have closed words then the interesting
thing is that if I have closed words
then I have a flow preservation property
in this graph that says that every the
sum of the flows that are incoming to a
vertex is equal to the flow at the
outgoing going out from the vertex and
this is something that we will use and
abuse in our derivations because we know
and we are very it's very easy to count
these integer flow vectors for closed
words and asymptotically this doesn't
make a big difference because the counts
going to be asymptotically the same for
closed-end words that are not closed and
so what are we going to do something
really plain vanila basically we're
going to cast the counting problem for
the pasture flow for the profiles as a
problem of finding let me explain this
finding the integer points in a certain
polytop and how do we construct the
polytop we know that we have to have a
flow conservation equation for all the
profile vectors because we know if
you're looking at closed vectors a
closed words the sum of the incoming
flows has to be equal to the sum of the
outgoing flows so if u is a profile
vector of a closed word then it has to
satisfy the flow conservation equation
where B is an incidence matrix of the
graph and on top of it we have a sum of
flows converting conservation because we
would know in advance how many sub
strings we expect to see and if you
power these two constraints up you can
get a matrix a and a simple equation
that says a times u where u is a profile
vector is equal to the number of L grams
times the B vector which is a 1 0 0 0
and now counting the number of possible
profile vectors or flows boils down to
counting the integer points within this
polytop so this is a very interesting
connection because it says you can use
something that is known as Earhart
theory for polytopes
and it tells you how to do counting of
integer points in rational polytopes and
i know i have five minutes or a little
bit more so I'll just briefly tell you
some of the most interesting results
from Erhart theory just one result
Earhart came up with the idea of
something called the lattice point
enumerator and it's an enumerator which
tells you the how to take dilations
of a polytope which just means you take
points in the polytop multiply them by a
certain dilation factor and then
count the number of integer points in
various dilations of the polytopes and
this is what is called the lattice point
enumerator and one of his most useful
results at least for our work is that if
you have a rational polytope then this
lattice point a room enumerator is a
quasi polynomial in a quasi panel
polynomial think of a polynomial that
has coefficients that are periodic
functions so rather than having
coefficients from a certain field a
quasi polynomial has coefficients that
are periodic functions and it's
something that frequently appears in the
numerator of combinatorics so quasi
polynomials are not that uncommon in an
enumerative combinatorics and what you
can do
equipped with this result you can
basically show the following you can
enumerate the number of distinct
profiles and you can enumerate
equivalence classes the size of
different equivalence classes and the
observation is basically that these
results hold this even if you use
restricted de Bruyne graphs and the
scaling of the number of profiles is n
where n is the length of the sequence
the size of the constraint set in which
you allow your L grams to belong to and
the set the size of the vertex set and
in general finding the coefficient the
leading coefficient is hard but you can
do it computationally by using a program
called latte which uses techniques from
a really good professor at Michigan bar
V knock who I was very happy to take a
class with so if you're interested in
enumerated integer points and polytopes
check a program called latte sounds
yummy
so this is how you do the counting of
the integer points and polytopes but I
didn't tell you how to construct the
codes and if you remember even at the
beginning what I mentioned to construct
the codes we have to ensure very large
asymmetric distance but how are you
going to ensure this very
straightforward really not complicated
we are going to look at our Rash our
integer points in the
polytop flow polytop that i described
and we are going to intersect those
point the set of those points with the
points that satisfy the version of code
constraint those of you in the audience
probably heard about Versamark oats as
codes that are frequently used for
asymmetric error correction and the
codes are defined by using a
reed-solomon BCH code like matrix and
the constraint that looks very much like
rashaam of tena Gold's constraint so
you're taking all the code words that
satisfy the property that when you take
this matrix multiply the code word by
this matrix you get a fixed value beta
which modulo P where you basically have
to choose the parameters P and beta
carefully and what you do is now you
have to just do some bookkeeping and
intersect the set of varsham of code
words with the set of integer points in
the poly top and get the result desired
result which tells you how many code
words you have that have profiles at the
very large distance from each other and
what is interesting is you are synthetic
ly really don't use lose anything in the
order of the code size you're still
gonna get this scaling n to the power s
minus vs a different constant because we
have different constraints but the
result carries over in the in the same
way so a lot of there are things and
results and I was rushing to finish on
time I know it's lunchtime a lot of
results that I didn't mention and in
particular how do you reconstruct the
words from the profiles it's obvious you
just follow an oil aryan path in the
drawing graph and the oil aryan path
will pass each edge once and if you have
edges of a certain weight or flow weight
then you're going to pass that edge that
many times and that's what will give you
the reconstructed word but there are
some things that you can actually do in
bio hardware to avoid looking at oil
aryan paths and computing oil aryan
tasks which is what i thought Mike was
asking all those details can be found in
the paper and in the paper you also have
a description of how do we do encoding
and I think Aria brought that up once
when we disk
busted I can construct the profiles but
when it comes to encoding is there an
efficient way to do encoding we have a
systematic encoder which starts with the
partial profile fill it out any way you
want it extends it to a valid a profile
and you don't have to worry about the
complexity of encoding either so there
is a lot of work here's compressed into
30 minutes I'll be around and I'll be
happy to talk to you about any more
details or more of the mathematical
formulation of this problem and other
related problems and just so that it's
not just the bio crazy talk I'm
interested in other things as well so if
you want to talk about correlation
clustering or anything else please talk
to me don't be scared by the bio I work
that I'm presenting here thanks a lot by
nature reading or sequencing is
destructive if that's the question you
cannot read the technology we have right
now don't allow us to read long
sequences we can read only short very
very very short compared to the length
of the genomes we have for example
standard lengths or fragments are
roughly hundred with Illumina PacBio has
can go 2,000 2,000 but they have a
horrible error rate right now so by
nature you chop off the sequence not one
you have millions of copies of the same
sequence you chop it off each the copies
chopped off randomly and then you hope
to have large overlapping fragments you
can stitch together together through an
oil aryan path problem so it's
destructive but you have so much DNA you
know you're not you take this little
sample of the DNA you amplify it they're
very cheap procedures for amplifications
and then you sacrifice it for sequencing
purposes you have to chop it up so for
each
read operation music produce replicas
which will be destroyed yes yes but that
that is not a big deal
because you have a solution with many
many many sequences you take a tiny
amount of that solution you do what is
called polymerase chain reaction it's an
exponential applique application that
works really really fast for whatever
sample you took it's an endless supply
and the machinery is there to do it very
efficiently so you're it's it's not a
resource constraint
the problem is synthesizing when you
synthesize it yeah you get millions and
millions of those sequences you don't
get one sequence you wouldn't know what
to do very quickly in the length you
should get to be able to write
everything right that there should be no
restrictions on body camera oh yeah so
that's the holy grail of biotechnology
making the reads longer and as I said
that's a big technological bottle like
the reads we have right now most of them
are hundred alumina 150 maybe 300 with
my seek or high C I mean how many do you
have to exclude it seems it should be
very little
oh I mean how many profiles can I take
out how much all the sequences forget
about the initial errors because then
you can just get rid of by precoding
right so that the right process is
exactly so so then just from the rich
process writing you lose in the read
process you lose a lot of fragments you
don't get all fragments and you have
errors there's no oh yeah yeah yeah you
can oh of course
yeah if you do it repeatedly right once
then is there
from to reconstruct there is a problem
to reconstruct because of a lot of
losses and you have you the problem is
you can do it many times but the red
channel is not really random because if
your sequence for example has very many
GCS in a substring
it's never gonna fragment in that part
because the GC is foreign very strong
bonds three hydrogen bonds between G and
C vs a and T and so breaking the
sequence at that point is not going to
happen so you're going to constantly
miss some fragments and that's called a
coverage problem in biology so the
problem is not in terms of repeating
because in our case we can avoid that we
can design the sequence to have a
certain GC content and that's why I
brought it up but for real biology it's
much more complicated you don't have a
control over the sequence and you may
lose chunks of DNA because of the
particular structure of the sequence
it's not going to be covered in your
reads and then you cannot do anything
about stitching it back together so
there are this I can control but for
real bio where I cannot design the
sequences the problems are immense it's
a really difficult question sorry I went
way over time mainly the size of the
equivalence class of those profile yes
non synthesize DNA sequence you don't
have any control over you know as a
matter been any study word fish so that
their theory there is a code like is
there I mean just think about it this
way humans are so similar you saw
David's mentioning of snips single
nucleotide polymorphisms we differ so
little in our genomes our code words are
really really close and what do you were
really interested in is those places
where we differ and getting that out is
really hard
which one of them I mean they're only
from what I remember only three
Neanderthal genomes we have and it's
easy to say it's in the under cell
because you get the whole genome and yes
why did you choose to write long lengths
and not just blocks of 100 oh I'll tell
you I'll tell you that's I if we can
take it offline if you want to or so
that's what the group from Cambridge did
they took hundred block lengths and they
made sure they overlap in exactly 25
they kept the problem is you need
address sequences and I really didn't
want to talk about that because how are
you gonna do random access if you don't
have address sequences and if you start
adding address sequences that allow you
to do random access to the hundred
length blocks you're doomed you have you
take a huge hit under it right so this
is what we're going for larger block
lengths because we can do random access
in a much more efficient way